تم الإعلان عن صفقة تاريخية للتو
في مؤتمر المناخ COP 28 في
دبي تحث الدول لأول
مرة على التحول من
الوقود الأحفوري المسؤول عن ظاهرة الاحتباس الحراري أه لكن
الصفقة الجديدة لا تلزم الدول
بالتخلص التدريجي منه تماما بدلا من ذلك
تقدم  سلسلة من ثمانية خيارات للحد من
الانبعاثات وتطلب من الدول
الاقتباس للمساهمة في هدف صافي
انبعاثات الكربون الصفرية بحلول عام 20150 بينما
تترك الاتفاقية ثغرات مفتوحة من
شأنها أن تسمح بمواصلة استخدام زيت الفحم
والغاز، ويقول بعض خبراء المناخ إن
العلامة التي تفعل ذلك حقًا  بمناسبة بداية
نهاية عصر الوقود الأحفوري،
ينضم إلينا ديف ماكنزي لمزيد من ردود الفعل
على الصفقة ولا يمكننا التقليل من
مدى صعوبة إدخال عبارة
الوقود الأحفوري حتى في هذا
الإعلان، حسنًا، هذا صحيح، ماكس
أعني إذا كنت  انظر إلى المسودة التي
رأيناها بالأمس حول محاولة الحصول على
الوقود الأحفوري هناك، لم تكن حتى في
مسودة البيان الصادر عن قمة COP 28،
لذا نعم هذا بالتأكيد تقدم،
العديد من أه الدول تتسيد هذه الصفقة
حتى النشطاء يقولون أن هذا يظهر
خطوة تاريخية بعيدًا عن الوقود الأحفوري في
المستقبل القريب للسماح للعالم
بمكافحة أسوأ آثار
أزمة المناخ، هناك ثغرات
ويشير الناس بالفعل إلى ذلك أه
يدعو إلى خيار احتجاز الكربون
والتكنولوجيا غير المثبتة على نطاق واسع
إنه يوفر ثغرات للبلدان
التي لا تزال تتطلع إلى استغلال
الوقود الأحفوري، لكن كما تعلمون فقط أنا
أنظر إلى بعض الصياغة الرئيسية هنا، كما
تعلمون التسارع نحو التخفيض التدريجي
لطاقة الفحم بلا هوادة، وهي
خطوة مهمة للغاية قام بها العالم
مدمن على الفحم، كما تعلم
منذ مئات السنين، ومن المحتمل أن يكون هذا
اجتماعًا مهمًا للغاية.
قال رئيس الشرطي سوان الجبا إن هذه كانت
لحظة تاريخية حيث قدمنا
استجابة شاملة للمخزون العالمي وجميع
التفويضات الأخرى التي واجهناها معًا
الحقائق وقد وضعنا العالم في
الاتجاه الصحيح، لقد قدمنا ​​له
خطة عمل قوية للحفاظ على 1.5 في
متناول اليد بشكل جيد، وسيكون المفتاح هو تنفيذ
هذه الخطة، ولأنها لا
تملي على البلدان التخلص التدريجي من
الوقود الأحفوري، فستظل هناك  أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك الكثير من
الأمور في المستقبل، أه ماكس، ما
رأيك في جولة واحدة مع تلك
الدول الرافضة مثل المملكة العربية السعودية والكويت
والعراق حسنًا، أعتقد أنه كان هناك
قدر هائل من الضغط القادم من العديد من
الدول، وكانت أكثر من 100 دولة
ترغب في ذلك  لدينا لغة أكثر مباشرة
هناك الآن والتي تشمل أه عمالقة الوقود الأحفوري
مثل الولايات المتحدة
والاتحاد الأوروبي أه كتلة الأمم أه ولكن أيضًا
دول جزر المحيط الهادئ التي
تواجه أسوأ ويلات
أزمة المناخ أعتقد أن كلاً من
السلطة الأخلاقية و ال  الضغط القادم أه
من الأمم المتحدة وغيرها
كان سيدفعنا أه إلى تجاوز الخط
ولكن من المعتاد في هذا النوع من
المفاوضات أه التحرك نحو طرف
متطرف ثم نلتقي نوعًا ما في مكان ما
في الوسط هذا
نهج إجماعي بحوالي 200  دول
العالم، ومرة ​​أخرى، يجدر التأكيد على
أن ما يحدث بالفعل الآن هو أنه
يتعين على الدول أن تضع
أموالها في مكانها الصحيح وأن
تحدث هذا التحول في السنوات العشر إلى العشرين القادمة.